greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
May 4th the church is brought to you by
and welcoming magic spoon let me ask you
a question remember when you were
kidding a breakfast cereal sitting in
your pajamas watching cartoons then you
drink the milk wouldn't it be fun to be
a kid again what do you think how fun is
it to be a kid now versus dad not I got
nothing for you there are no good
cartoons no good serials well I'll tell
you what magic spoon cereal gives you
all the flavor and the cup crunch of a
kid cereal but it's healthy for an adult
you ready for this zero grams of sugar
and three net grams of carbs and each
servings and and and 12 grams of protein
who needs a prize when you got all that
in one [ __ ] box and it tastes good I
gotta be honest to you they sent me the
chocolate they sent me the Froot Loops
my favorite is the chocolate so far and
the birthday cake they're thinking oh
[ __ ] the birthday cake a rock your world
so whatever you're a real Craven they
got cocoa fruity and blueberry plus a
variety pack that lets you try all the
flavors it's like a walk down memory
lane so do me a favor right now go to
magic spoon comm slash Church to grab a
variety pack and try it today and be
sure the pressing code Church CH you are
CH at checkout to get free shipping and
Magic School is so confident their
product it's backed by a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason don't refund your
money no questions asked
that's magic spoon comm slash Church and
use promo code Church for free shipping
when you try the chocolate cocoa your
mind is gonna [ __ ] blow up I can't
mention that it is delicious nutritious
and [ __ ] yummy
plus it's gluten free you know I'm
giving a box to Dean cuz he's diabetic
I gave a box of monomer C's friends
she called back right away that she
loved it so do me a favor right now go
to magic spoon comm slash Church and
grab a variety pack and press in Church
and check out and get free shipping
kick this [ __ ] muley
[Music]
[Music]
what
Cinco DeMayo tomorrow spent now
you gotta get a pinata beat it up in
your house by yourself drinking tequila
that's it you get six crap Mexicans
tomorrow it's all over
Nicole [ __ ] starts all over again the
grand holiday it's like why don't you
see abc6 Mexican listen it starts all
over ya so don't even get together
tomorrow
leave it alone especially if you
overweight like me you see a fat Mexican
move over especially Amaro because be
cold the day down in Texas you know
Texas is free tennis free is Tennessee
is free no [ __ ] live music on live
entertainment and Atlanta I'm praying
for you I know George is open I hope
you're making the best of it but it'll
give us a [ __ ] it's Monday the 4th and
you still got to do what the [ __ ] you
got to do you understand me we're gonna
open up today with this joint of xxx
from urban trees delicious I've been
getting stoned like a [ __ ] again
you understand me [ __ ] the culprit as
long as I'm exercising I'm smoking
reefer how's that one for you and this
we're gonna have a good week
I discovered you guys have no idea
listen I can do a pantry on are just
videos of me riding a bicycle and you
pay understand me you have no idea what
comedy is until you see me on my wife's
bicycle [ __ ] holding on to those
bicycle things like it's my work right
now my triceps hurt more than anything
else in my body or his family you can
hit me in the head with a bat I won't
even react because I'm holding onto
those handlebars so [ __ ] deal I've
I've been doing I started off slow I did
she got the bike last week I took like
five minutes now hold on let me spark
this joint so I can tell you the story
correctly so I don't miss a [ __ ] line
here so you guys know the humor that I
have in my life by itself
I don't leave microphones I'm thinking
about Layla I just got a [ __ ] camera
with a stick like a selfie film that's
all I need then you can save me full
life
electrocute myself with the [ __ ]
hearing aids when I wash my face you can
live it you can see all the stupidity
and all the dice [ __ ] wait you let's not
get into it please don't embarrass me I
got no problems I gotta tell these
people about so
his V you [ __ ] little number
just to let you know I'm thinking about
you and I love you [ __ ] with
all my heart I know it's a tough time
but we're going through this
[ __ ] together so strap on a pair
[ __ ] we're all gonna get stronger than
shift from this so couple you know you
can just do so much with your kids so we
got the bike she kept a little [ __ ]
how many I put it around the name but
she has a good time she lied to ride a
bike during the [ __ ] break so I'm
very excited about that so my wife says
you know what maybe I should get a bike
I go you should get a bike so we went
looking around and all the bike you know
usually a bike place has bicycles
outside not here
they got him inside like everybody's
gonna item for me like it so you got I
gotta go inside and buy a bike [ __ ]
I'll just make my own bike so my wife
goes I could order one online I go yeah
order a huffy all mine like when those
cheap puppies and she didn't get home
one day there's a bicycle like a Puerto
Rican she's building the bicycle and
whatever room her in mercy they're
putting wd-40 on the chain the whole
[ __ ] deal now when somebody tells me
that building their own bicycle I don't
get on that bicycle unless you're a
bicycle bill gonna be a [ __ ] problem
so not to mention I got a lot when it
comes to bicycles and she like I got a
lot of bad karma coming to me and I know
this already that's why I stopped riding
bicycle because I just got a lot of bad
karma you know for years I wrote a
bicycle people always getting [ __ ]
killed on him and [ __ ] I feel like I got
I love coming to me so I got to be
careful
I ordered the helmet I did order Alma
but let's get to that story so I see my
wife build the bicycle and I go do me a
favor double check the pedal bars so the
pedals don't break double check the
thing the chain cuz I worry about my
wife put some thing on the chain and
make sure you screwing the [ __ ]
handlebars why do I say that we go back
to 1978 when Valentin Farrow was going
on my block in the Apollo racer and he
almost killed himself I'm the [ __ ]
thing does the handlebars right Andre
so a friend of mine calls me and he goes
hey I'm taking my kids to the park we're
a social distancing if you'd like to go
to get your daughter some air I go
absolutely as a matter of fact my wife
got a bike I'll walk over and my wife
and daughter ride the bike they get
their half hour before me you know me
I'm [ __ ] taking my time I'm getting
vitamin D no problem I get to the thing
my wife and daughter doing summersaults
with the other four kids around the
track there's nobody at the [ __ ] park
to three o'clock
[ __ ] these so many cons come out
after 4:30 like vampires five o'clock in
my neighborhood there's a [ __ ] parade
but before that you can rub ten houses
but you really can't cuz they're all in
the house
there's nobody out so my wife is talking
to the lady
everybody's got masks on we're very
social distancing I'm looking at her
bike and I figured what the [ __ ] let me
get on her bike and give it a spin it's
been a long time you know but bikes bike
is like getting your dick sucked it's
like sucking a dick for a [ __ ] it's
something you'll never forget you know
saying what you think you'll never
forget it so I get on the bicycle guys
well I finally got my balance how most
had a nervous breakdown
I felt muscles worked at and worked in
years I just started shivering on the
bicycle and I have no reason to lie to
you guys after two minutes tops
my whole body broke out into this sweat
like that anxiety fear sweat because I
really hadn't been on a bicycle and Here
I am the paddling you know it's not a
five-speed bike it's important recent
bike its leg power I'm saying that those
are Chinese bicycles that like follow
unless you're coming direct from Wu Han
your legs better be [ __ ] strong so
I'm battling guys after two minutes I'll
judge the key
I stopped to make believe I was
answering a question but I stopped
because my body had nervous so I can
break that Wow
so I went home that night I did my
regular work and I said [ __ ] it I'm
gonna do five minutes on the bike today
so every day before they leave at 8:15
in the morning I jump out there get on
the bike before I take a shower
and I just write it down to the corner
so everyday I just started out in five
minutes so when they leave sometimes
when I when we all leave together I go
with them and when they get sick and
tired of riding I walk while they ride
and then when they get sick and tired of
riding I take my wife's [ __ ] a little
Nazi helmet you got to see me I look
like Hitler quick gonna wait watches hey
man you gotta see me with this helmet on
it's like yeah I gotta put a little
stash on me and Jews will be sparked
[ __ ] flying off Koufax with a car
it's like a green nazi helmet I didn't
buy it to be a Nazi you know me yeah my
Wyatt doll those helmets look like Nazis
like when I was growing up those helmets
looked okay like like Mercy's is okay
right the one they sent Terry Nazi those
people died like the [ __ ] Capitol
jumping up and down right now with
weapons and [ __ ] so I put it on like a
fat I look like Hitler in Argentina
years later you didn't saying when he
was relaxing in the a jury so even
Mongol Oh whatever his name is the other
[ __ ] Nazi Mengele what's his name
Mengele Mengele yeah whatever is [ __ ]
name is so every day I've been riding my
bike five ten fifteen so right now I'm
up to twenty five [ __ ] minutes but I
gotta tell you something every muscle in
my lower body and then my sides hurt but
I don't give a [ __ ] it's been an
adventure this is like I told you
there's gonna be a silver lining to this
quarantine we got a lot we got a lot of
[ __ ] going it's so funny how my
creativity has responded lately for
[ __ ] four or five weeks I couldn't
get arrested now I'm outlining outlining
outlining outlining I'm trying to
outline this [ __ ] oral this book I'm
trying to do this audiobook okay I see
Lee brothers flies back in I can't
believe he's back and they're back on
them heavy because he's sweating all
that old humus out by walking so it sits
on the skin and it's like oh [ __ ] and
he's like a frosted flake you know I'm
saying he's like a
sugar ball right now all these flies
wanna sniff his neck
that's what happens when he works out
that's a downfall of when Lee works out
that flies become his friends again he's
at home right now with two flies pactum
singing bent them and whatever the [ __ ]
he does this joints on fire but a you
can't walk on one [ __ ] leg we're
doing a little head of woods Monday I
respect to you [ __ ] I didn't
bring one Lilly last time I gave one of
these to leave we're just sleeping eight
hours before the cops came in here yeah
we can't do that the end of Monday
morning you got [ __ ] to do on people to
see on top of that I don't want to share
it with you because I thought I'd give
you the co bit yeah I'm saying
who knows if I got it I just know yeah I
think you I don't want to share [ __ ]
I'm going deep on a Monday morning
either respect for the church family
salut
[ __ ] it you can't walk on one leg
[ __ ] that's what I'm trying to
tell you now as promised since its new
co vid in this new situation you know we
had to lose a lot of guests and move a
lot of guests around I finally we
modernized myself and boom we got zoom
[ __ ] and like I promised you
guys I want to do a little comeback here
I want to go back to the early days of
church when it was just us and uh you
know we had a certain guest pool because
we weren't in the same guest pool as
everybody else
so what I want to do out of respect for
my church is have my church for my book
is the audiobook is I want to interview
a couple of my friends on the podcast
just so you get to meet them get the
mentality get to understand what they're
coming from today I got a kid that I've
been friends with you ready for this for
43 years
I've met him the some of my eighth grade
year playing the guitar it took us two
years to connect and after that we
couldn't break this apart when I call
him before my mother died you know that
BC and AC he
before my mother died so he's family he
went to my mother's wake he came to her
funeral and I consider him a brother his
name is Steve of the law he's got two
older brothers and they considered me
brothers and when my mother died
Stephen even asked me if I wanted a
bedroom in the house so we've
reconnected over the years through
comedy and his band called the past
masters which is uh you know he's mighty
guy as you see in the interview
I know number for years I'll know what
the [ __ ] he does I don't K he's my
brother only that he does but we
reconnect he does little videos this
series on as you on his facebook every
night Stephen envelope you follow him
he does music and he's a great musician
I mean let me tell you some this kid's
been a musician since I met him his
common sense and his it scientism and
his whole thing you know kept him into
the family life he's got a beautiful
family I grew up with his wife
I know his two daughters just a
beautiful beautiful individual when I'm
raising mercy I think about this guy a
lot and I think about his parents raised
him because he's got two other brothers
and himself and all three of them a
gentleman this is Steve a Volvo I hope
you enjoy the interview
knock yourself out ticket Lee
Steve I'll owe you 40 years I don't know
you I'm Anna I'm an IT guy
so I basically do you know IT support
engineering new new you know you find
new things you figure out ways of how
they fit the business and stuff like
that so it just keeps me busy and out of
trouble
my kid like his friends think I'm in the
CIA cuz I'm on with China and different
countries all hours and night people
don't know I grew up with Steven we met
when I was about 14 I went to one of his
band things at the Louie field and your
guitar broke you were playing with John
ray I go how to be somewhere 78 and who
was the bass player to you then Dennis
to Karla Jesus Christ
yeah that's the first time I met you cuz
I didn't I didn't grow up will I live
good luck Bergen but I like to school in
Kearny so I didn't really do anything
much in North Bergen just you in the
city where my mother had the bar so
that's why they've know you cats growing
up and then once I got thrown out of
Capitol school I was forced to look up
were you [ __ ] sandy just lucky okay
County rainbows band by the way that was
and that was his band yeah him and Mike
beckoned back Mike Lee bow then is the
Carlo on bass and Jeremy Schwartz the
late Jerry Schwartz was this singer they
let me sit him with them so I was the
funny thing when you saw as I was saying
they were nice enough to let me sit a
well let let in a little punk send him
with him yeah you do like 13 yeah
because I was about 13
well 13 14 and I still remember like not
tripping we're just smoking pot back
then
and me going up there and the car spring
breaking huh I wasn't even doing that
yet and Tom we wanted to Invicta that a
joke we passed was high school
definitely uh definitely when things
started to change
let me actually you know when I I've
been doing the podcast for seven years
and when I talk about lockberg and Steve
it was it like another world we grew up
in it's another world another time I
wouldn't trade it for the world that's a
show I mean I still remember banging on
his door the bar on 39th Street there
and kept off for Kennedy and like you
bang on the door he would sleep on the
pool table and you'd bang on his door in
Florida we had the coldest beer in the
world when they come up like where else
if that should happen you know I'm the
one there are only times I play both you
with you we were just walking past
Wizards because we used to go to a place
Wizards forget Mike nickel bags and
stuff I don't know who the creepy guy
wasn't wizards like pedophiles I'm out
up there and stuff like that like I
never even went into wizards and told by
what the high school like I never knew
Wizards existed and I remember one
morning walking past Wizards and the guy
was delivering beer to uh to the liquor
store there that later became a shway
and like the embers they already had a
system on how to throw the beer guy off
and we would open up the back and take a
case of beer and run and that they would
trace this one time we probably cases
that I school and mr. Lee asked me to
open up my locker and I told them unless
he had a war he could know because
having a 12-pack but Michelob and there
was some [ __ ] his everybody took the
six-packs and hit him in the walkers
yeah that time on me I told mr. Lee get
the [ __ ] out of my face that if he
didn't have a warrant he wasn't getting
in my locker and that was the end of my
relationship
mr. Lee was a tough bastard we was
[ __ ] tough ex-marine his lay that we
made amends and we became friends and
when I lived in Colorado I would keep in
touch with them one day his son called
me and told me he died yeah memories I
can still remember we were just we would
assume it was it was so damn cold
outside we went into there was a senior
poles leaving juniors I don't know if
you were with me I know Dede was daddy
you probably were there I was there we
we had you know in our jackets we had
put all the beers and jackets to go in
and we finished everything went to the
bathroom we're down to the last beer it
said Lucy and oh yes I was with you eh
come they come storming in and they're
like laces and North beragon for you to
drink
why do you have to drink here school and
then he turns - have you been outside
tonight it's [ __ ] freezing then the
next day it's all go downstairs yep
sitting in the room and mr. Dalton
bailed us out yeah who came in God
blesses so he goes these guys have good
kids let him go and you know we never
even got a [ __ ] fraction nothing I
mean it was such a I still remember clip
in a case of course that weren't cold
and we had to put him in somebody's tub
and put ice on him because you know how
cold it you not do all it takes to
[ __ ] choke a [ __ ] quart of beer
like I don't know how many beer trucks
we arrived but it was pretty [ __ ]
hysterical we were kids it was a lot
more when one of us started to drive
like when sharples chiapas is three
years old in us when Tommy used to drive
that was that that was the best thing
because you didn't need anybody to
distract you just kind of circle the
block like on Broadway and stuff by
embassy liquors and keep an eye on the
pitch up or pull up you've watched the
guy watching loader to show you watch
him go in as soon as he went in flew
down a block ripped open the sign you
just started passing he's my car and you
take all over someone at one time Robert
cases of beer and they would hold the
back to my pad
she hang out the window yes to be is
Nicola car I mean it was so because of
us now they have two drivers yeah yeah
and for one and if it was the beer truck
it was the Albertson's I'm burning line
Avenue and down the wine that roast
Rosie martini and Rossi cooking wine I'm
taking a gallon once running out of how
persons and going at the Hudson County
Park and drinking the whole [ __ ]
thing and I'm having a hangover for a
whole goddamn weekend I think I had the
worst headache I've never drank from
that damn a cheap wine get him bad hang
on man [ __ ] Albert says had no
security the more yes and we would just
basically clean walk in there take the
beers and run the [ __ ] out it's hard to
even you know it's hard to Eve our
childhoods and you were good guy like
you you were like that a straight a type
of guy I started you know you like we
explained to the people with then we
were out six nights a week
yeah we were six nights a week our light
light was Sunday night that was like we
just low content joints today and when
drinking a six-pack each that was on
weight that our light light was sad lace
we found an excuse for anything to go
out and we drank out Nicole yeah he
drank out Nicole was snow didn't matter
if it was snowing you'd be out you'd be
out in a foot of snow and a drinking
glove one glove we had drinking plugs
and extreme hello loves that's the tips
were cut off this [ __ ] then you know
it's just when I look at you when you
come to the shows I'm so happy because
it's like my life is like Jesus it's
like before Christ died and after Christ
died and you one of my friends before my
mom passed and one of the the best
stories I tell people is you know your
brother was old
he has his own clique and they were
great to hang around with them the
recruiting and then you invited me and
somebody else over to a party once this
had a piece of number 79
Razak morning and your brothers made
this thing and they made it in garbage
cans you're talking about the punch
right punch they would they would go and
get like big blocks of ice from
trailhawk they stealing from the trailer
park they buy one bag ice and stealing
12 blocks ice the sherbert freak make
stuff like that and then they put water
in from a hose and in every and any
bottle that people could bring was
poured into that I mean it was funny
there was Scotch vodka gin moonshine
anything and everything went into that
punch including insects kettledrum
killing bees and for knocking the bees
into the punches like that freaking cake
from a little rascal just a mousetrap
the shoe that night I don't know what I
drank it was like beer and the punch
combined and I fell asleep on Ritchie
sisulu's lon
if I walk to your house I would have to
walk past Richardson sue Lowe's house
mm-hmm
and he lived like a block and a half for
me to say yeah yeah heading headed
towards five corners and I'll never
forget that round that's though woke me
up the cop that used to always play
basketball of waters with colored socks
it used to drive me crazy it we had to
teaches that play winners it was him he
played basketball with us ray honest oh
and mr. Keller er it's the guy with mr.
K with the Kruk at night but I still
remember I like the Rihanna
so whenever we can play basketball with
him we throw elbows out just because
always colored sides we wore an avenue
like in those days of you went to gym
class would call it sucks they would say
yeah because if you stepped on glass the
ink would go into your bloodstream [ __ ]
you know when you play basketball on
those cords to them those points will
not tame them rough those are some great
games 51st Street that's the great games
on the air you write down on me yes
that's where I'll be viewed as a fool oh
those were some tough games there 38th
Street Court yeah and the coordination
with the courts my hash ways Jesus I'm
playing one-on-one they're 3:00 in the
morning with your sister Lord Danny
calendar low my 8th grade sug that's
crazy [ __ ] like no curfew did you have a
curfew I don't remember us having a girl
I I did have a curfew
I remember I was supposed to be home by
11:00 and a lot of times going home I
run into my brothers especially my
brother Mike my brother Mike would
always say we go and like going home
yeah getting a car I'll call mom so
you'd stop you know he'd be going to get
more beer whatever he'd stopped at a pay
phone yes Stephens with me and I'd be
out till who knows what time you know
but yeah I was I was it was like I think
when I was a freshman and a sophomore
was like 11 junior I was allowed out to
like midnight one and then senior year
there was no curve Dyke even if it was
it was not adhered to you know you just
show up and there's a comedian in town
his name is Brett arts he's from New
Jersey there's a bit that in Jersey
there's always that one kid who doesn't
go home like when he said the bit I was
dying to laugh because downtown I was
kid I had nowhere to go so I wouldn't go
home an uptown it was Mike Moore
it was a kid named Mike Moore I just
bought a gentleman Rudy's about three
years ago you could be walking home you
had already given up on the night you're
like [ __ ] and I'm going home and I
wasn't boom you bump into my car and I
mean it was just it was just [ __ ]
started you know like I wouldn't go home
me and beanie had no reason go home so
we would stay with you you had a shed
yeah thank God that had a pair drums in
it Danny loads he's no pissed at me I'm
playing this [ __ ] drums because we
used to play fairies wear boots at night
uh yeah my childhood respect for two
years and that [ __ ] shed you know
yeah yeah a lot of good times back then
you notice no pictures I want okay
because we have no pictures we didn't we
weren't a picture society and count you
couldn't take out a [ __ ] selfie those
days their braids are finally slow need
myself able to be money yes we will be a
month there was no selfies there's
really no pictures of us and we were
kids that wasn't accepted had a party
you know I told I went down my friend
created this show called this is not
happening and before was created it was
created in a in the back of the improv
then corn with the workspace no alcohol
no nothing and I went down and a kind of
story about something and while I was
down there Marc Maron was telling the
story by going to a concert
so right there had a call inaudible and
tell him the experience we had at the
age of 15 in 1979 what we went through
to get paid for tickets how might you
start from the beginning from the night
before
oh my god
thank you still I can still remember
always it foot poke with it with the
with the joint and the joint or the
ashes fell on his lap or burned his
shirt he's like put himself out driving
full speed down Boulevard and he's doing
this not paying attention where he's we
first we went out to like I think you
told me the night before I always hit
the pink floor and I had Dark Side of
the Moon and I met you I had Dark Side
of the Moon and then my mom passed
November 8th and if you look at it yeah
of 1979 and tickets one on Sam closely
right after that from Nassau Coliseum
which is obviously in February you know
and you told me the night before to get
my money together we're getting tickets
blah blah blah yeah and we had a play
hooky there was no we cut on her school
you myself and LeBron oh and I don't
know how we ended up with Joe folk I
have no he was four years older than us
yeah I don't know how we ended up with
Joe folk at first we went to the Paramus
mall to get tickets and they didn't have
him and then we went to st. Peter's Prep
yeah that's where we got the tickets for
$15.50 think about that huh think about
that 50 Cent's and we got the tickets we
were like it's tough for me that this
you know one of our friends lost their
mom last week go and copy you know yeah
and I spoke with Don Keith god bless
their mom and stuff and it was weird
because I didn't even have a chance to
mourn as soon as I was getting ready and
my mom that you guys started playing the
[ __ ] war and it was like a 60-day
countdown to the wall yeah we did
everything every night we put the wall
on every night
every party we went to the wall you know
I still remember going to parties if
somebody had Springsteen on we think
Springsteen are off and put the [ __ ] the
wall on and that it was you know
Christmas we didn't care we were just
waiting for the war it was our saving
night and we got tickets for opening
night midnight and I think in the
process of that before the war was the
evening of the eyelid yes that was
before it got really cold yeah what was
because no no no no that was when it was
really cold because we had a way too
late to freeze off I'm having a senior
moment here no listen to me
the lake freeze froze over in January
yes we went to see the wall in February
so that January was in Hudson County
Park this little island in the middle
and there's water around what do you say
30 yards around and we would wait till
it freezes up and Anthony's older
brothers stay I'm your older brother
Woodrow pegs on the answer we'd have to
walk across the hybrid to go to the
island of insanity party party so I
could they know white things he's
building we just went on it with nothing
on that we takes a beer and I don't know
Matt might I froze my Ashlock like it
was freezing and I had a quaalude and I
ended up with chirpy and focal ratio and
wing phung's Chinese restaurant the
place we used to run out of dining and
folk was so hammered that he fell asleep
for the pork fried rice and he was
breathing he was briefly tried rice
until his nose and when the Chinese guy
woke them up yeah like it drops the rice
come alive his nose and meal looms were
howling and then we ran out of there
because you never paid that the wig [ __ ]
no that was the Berkshire it used to be
even less guys got it and the last guy
was always the fastest one I've ever ran
out
because I like that [ __ ] creme of
turkey soup yeah it always came with a
hair in it or something like that no it
actually contains some that's a sweet
potato so examine the macaroni salad
will always have that hair around one of
the macaronis if you didn't get an had
you felt like you got beat you on lunch
like he won love the giving of a piece
of herring his sandwich you complained
about a piece and you know yeah but I
he's still even told the story on with
like concert and there was one point the
concerts on YouTube which is amazing to
me yeah that's um you know that right
mm-hmm
that night that we went it's on YouTube
it's so weird that at one point like we
stopped the concert was an eight and I
think me you will lose my I got eleven
in the morning we got ready early and
when we got there was probably fifty
kids from our neighborhood he's opening
like easy we had like the whole I
remember we had our trunks open at the
Nassau Coliseum
mm-hm and we were out there freezing
gammy I was yelling so sure about any
quiz the theater tonight or some [ __ ]
you see Alan something we were laughing
our asses off for that the scene I
remember vividly is in between take
wanted to when the balloons come up and
focal ratio was running the balloons as
they were landing and you and me would
just sit there we were kids man yeah
he's right popping him with the light
act he was with the lighter we have like
some girl behind us or in front of us
and she's like sure sure
why do you keep burning the balloons or
something and he's like Satan doesn't
like balloons
she just looked at us God it was just a
different time growing up the reason I
don't know how many times do you went to
the garden that was next
synonym itself just the whole trip down
there it was like such an event right
you know when you think about it that we
used to get together early right we get
together early we party and everything
and then we'd walk up to Kennedy
Boulevard and catch the bus and you
catch the bus say at the top of 46th
Street if you came over to the shed and
everything we'd walk up 46th Street Hill
you catch the bus there and on the bus
already would be friends of ours from
different parts of town they'd be packed
from up in 70s packed down by you know a
50s and 60s the projects we get on
they'd be more people down a little bit
further and then you'd head into you
know Port Authority once you got off the
walk down a head and it was another trip
you know it was a whole big procession
until you got there you know so it was
just such an experience Stephen we would
15 yeah so many things could have
happened to us and we would walk around
like we ran that [ __ ] city we didn't
give a [ __ ] 15 years old nice to see Ted
with you with a CBC yeah August 4 79 how
many of us were at that concert we were
in Orchestra that would throw on the
chairs in here you remember remember the
giant pile of chairs that whole section
walkers were just started throwing
chairs in here I don't think I was with
you that night but I was no I was a with
you I was a petty to double the amount
then he was yeah it's a good name he's
doing time now
well he is yeah so but just that
experience that we had and brought it to
New York City whenever we wanted to our
parents had no idea we could tell them
we were ball up the corner and we would
be in the city with him you know ten
minutes and what
connected you and me was our love for
music we went to every [ __ ] concert
you know how many times did you go to
the Palladium is a kid played Ian
palladium more than a Capitol Theater
because she had to drive to get to the
Capitol theist again acclaim him a lot I
didn't see a lot of people to cap will
see there I only saw like missing
persons later on with birdie at the Met
there and I like to see yeah I was
telling the story about Ethan quaaludes
with Bernie and Roger and going to see
Pat Benatar we got so high doctor I
should thought we were handicapped and
they posed in a handicapped section and
we just sat there like [ __ ] right but
they better take it we had would
suddenly working on tonight my brother
ah God I haven't even thought about it I
have a couple that I was playing around
with one was hotter than matter by
Henley what was the other one what was
the other one I was mucking around with
I was monkeying around with um just sold
by STP they just a love song you know
that yeah well I I have a couple of
different things that didn't plane like
I know most of these songs so I relearn
them because I have forgotten half of
them so I relearned and when I feel like
you know I feel like I had the time to
sit down like I had this week I'll sit
down and I'll record it and throw it out
there if people like it they like it
they don't they don't it's okay okay
it's the main tip of the rector's our
lives took I mean you know love from
music it's still evident used to have a
band the past masters yes play all over
the tri-state area and I still sit here
in shock but I ended up a comedian I
mean I can't believe it you know it was
late what's that you lose funny I think
that was more of a trickster as a kid
you know we always had when we got on
the bus I mean we hadn't walked those
hills couple years ago you had some type
of surgery
you're gonna be fine because we walked
those hills yeah you know I look at
those hills now in a car and I get
scared and we have to walk up those
hills backwards drinking coffee laughing
giggling like nothing it would take this
three hours to walk a 46 read a letter
yeah
those hills made their long and steep up
them ride the bike up them yeah yeah I
mean we walked up that hill an average
of three times a day do you think about
that in the morning to go to school and
then at night sometimes they wouldn't
want to use the bus we come through a
goddamn cemetery yes who cut through a
cemetery and the reason why I was scared
of your area 46 was because they told me
that that hill when it would rain it
would wash up the cemetery and the
caskets would float down is that true
the car first moved into that house when
he was a kid that the cemetery had
washed up the bottom of the hill and
then a casket they had to come down
there and [ __ ] clean the casket up
that I come out so I always was spooked
by 4060 know there was that and it was
the one like by Larry McNeil's house
gallon that's Barry
flowey used to walk to that all the time
he's tied to the [ __ ] now one night it
was freezing I couldn't take it and the
guy the guy was like buried in 1891 I'm
like [ __ ] he's got no relatives you
know the guy was old you know it was
freezing I couldn't take it
you remember you'd walked through there
and you'd see like the candles and
decapitated like chicken heads and saw
yeah they did some dirty stuff in there
at night that was that was real I got
chased one night by some guy is wearing
like black cloaks in there one night and
I just kept right on it because you came
out on 51st Street there was a whole
defense
yeah looking bad something like not a
man of you man
right right there are men who has
the Bell was quite the childhood we had
man too bad it's all over them you know
what you got memories my friends I live
I live we have each other's backs
yeah it's a different world today you
know can you imagine if they were tried
to tell us to stay in 1980 you know I
had the same conversation with Johnny
ray go the other day and he says he goes
he says to me go those of us think I'll
be honest what he was he was this thing
scares me he goes and I was joking about
it he goes but I've become the person
that had made fun of my entire life
you know it's funny I said you know
you're right man I said we would have
you know we would have basically just
called you [ __ ] it's wrong with you
it's not right do you think we would
build a shed yes we would have not
adhered to this we may have paid a price
who knows who knows what happened but
yeah we would have I understand I
understand people doing the things they
do I don't necessarily agree with it but
it's I mean my thing was I wasn't gonna
hold this shoot and go watch you play on
the 14th I'm sad laying guttenberg of
March and I just saw the whole framework
and like every day the news got worse
after it was like it was quick so and I
hear now that New Jersey is a hotbed you
know governor Murphy's only going to
open up the part of the state and I'm
like if they think that these live cards
and California crazy when they open up
the beach what are you gonna do down
your seaside Memorial Day weekend are
you gonna keep those animals can you
imagine they telling us in 1982 don't
come down Shore never would never never
would have flowed now we would have been
arrested yeah it was a [ __ ] world we
wouldn't have kids right but we also
were kids that we used to be it out yeah
I don't think it would have been as as
hyped up as it is today
well the media was nowhere we have a
centimeters the news was on like twice a
day
yeah maybe three times I guess it was on
the afternoon - we were at school at
lunchtime or something but they've told
you dick
yeah they didn't tell you [ __ ] you know
it's not like now that that they're
reaching for news you know they tell you
dick there's three hours of news on they
don't tell you dick at the last ten
minutes they show you either blind bored
I can play the drums like to try to you
know save the day but it's too late
you've already [ __ ] my mouth you know
I'm just saying that you want to give me
a [ __ ] lollipop it's too late my
brothers for the real pleasure I'm happy
you took the time cuz I wanted to
introduce the world the friends that
made me who I am today
and you're one of those guys you know
that was thinking about the other day I
was talking to Jegs
and we were talking about that year when
we started eating stuff you remember
people willing to eat was free and there
was a party for Halloween at the high
school and somebody's looking sweet
you're gonna hold your potato people
Peter people was he took a garbage can
and he tied live mice to the tails of
the garbage for the my you know there
was a no-name know there was a few of
the Jew eat a mouse now it wasn't me it
was it was I was I was still a junior
and it was the senior masquerade party
you're absolutely right
people that went as garbage and they had
like my
hanging from garbage can and they
started biting the mice and people
started crying scream crying and
vomiting and yeah I think I still
remember somebody fighting the mouse in
the tail just sticking out of the guy's
not why he was sleeping I think it was
Mike runny at the tail make this stuff
up
you can I was trying to think about a
couple blocks up a couple doors up from
Ron Burkle there was somebody that we
hung out with from time to time couple
doors up he was a football player who's
the guy that he could dog [ __ ] the day
that we were hanging around
kids we always pass the hat around for
everything he would always we would
always pass a hat around there you want
to get beers past three hours of two
hours a day
and then one day we played hooky and we
went to his house and his father was a
cop he took the gun down he start a
Russian Roulette
and he having a French poodle the
doggies take [ __ ] since the mob
would never clean up the fact he hurt so
when they were out there like eight of
us were reason we're passing the drawing
around out of nowhere he goes how much
would you give me a piece of [ __ ] what
was that kid I can't remember I can't
remember the name but I know who you're
talking about
there's no eating scream like people
would try to do it you know yeah he
would try and help each other he was it
yeah he was trying to outdo each other
and it was that whole thing like if you
think about it you had yet Ozzy and
Zappa and you had people who were trying
to gross each other out and wanna up
each other all the time
so you know we decided to do it too
which was you know what you think but
yeah mm-hmm you know there was mice
there was snakes there was oh that's
right we go to the cemetery and lock the
tombstones over there a little slaves
that live on the tombstones bringing the
snake that [ __ ] mix it's a powerful
snakes the counter and he always [ __ ]
for dick
Oh Nick please terrorizing Nick and his
own Nick Nick Nicole David but yeah Nick
was one of the best pizza guys we had
and all the Flies would land on it it
was like their takeoff there's like a
little airport for the Flies he used to
call you ayatollah khomeini
Nikolic oh man I shaved my head night I
tried to grow a beard it was a scraggly
disgusting looking thing but know that I
know and he's like Khomeini and he used
to call me Belushi fucked-up one so this
pizza parlor I like threw cutter Adam
and he banned me for like 30 days and he
forgave me but we then I got him iron
and we would never he had a close-up
that must have been funny weekly came
out to the car he said were you smoking
so we just came like ahead and we we
came back on our land to eat the pizza
parlor was closed we asked the next day
Nick what happened to you he's like that
smoke was good stuff because he had that
Greek accent yeah good stock Janna go
home yeah I go home hello it's a
pleasure to have you on my friend
I like this Zoo I'm starting to like it
though if I could see my old friends and
talk with them this will work we saw the
podcast talk some [ __ ] let's go can you
explain more about the throwing with
chairs at the concert he kind of just
glossed over throw away throwing at the
band chairs
no it was just you know
everybody like Ted Ted Nugent it was an
unbelievable show when we were sitting
Bon Scott ran through young on his
shoulders ran right past us we were in a
frontal orchestra section in front right
orchestra section if you're looking at
the stage and E so Ted comes out plays a
great show comes out again for an encore
you know and plays stranglehold and then
you know does cat scratch fever and you
know everybody's going crazy nobody's
leaving no the lights are up
nobody's leaving at meas Ted Ted Ted he
comes out again he plays a song by Chuck
Berry called Carol so he starts that
song off and with that somebody wasn't
one of us I don't claim to start this
thing somebody throws a charity Anna
it's all it had to be done next thing
you know all the lunatics that way with
just stop winking chairs it just
throwing him in the air and just
throwing him up in here and you see
these chairs flying and next thing you
know everybody's lobster section is
throwing chairs and people are getting
added away and there's this huge pile of
chairs with the seat of people around
and it was just you just saw things
flying in the air and there was nothing
that security could do about nothing if
I go back through the craziest concert
that had to be the one because I still
know getting on the bus then people had
ghetto blasters yeah playing highway to
hell on the bus the people would just go
over there to hang out even if they
didn't get tickets there was so many
scalpers from those days now you got a
ticket for 10 bucks 8 bucks 15 bucks you
know so but I still remember like just
being excited do you remember going to
see Ted out in the Meadowlands hell yeah
yeah I walked home back the Aerosmith
house was a terrible terrible it was too
[ __ ] hot and I still remember walking
on route green you could hear Ted [ __ ]
them wailing out there but it was just
an amazing how we were always safe yeah
in all those concerts
because there was so many of us from our
own town yeah well I still machine ac/dc
a palladium and we were all in one
section I had a before us on one section
we just took this section over you know
it's hard to tell people but it was true
I still remember going to see Hollywood
Delian him get into a fistfight because
soon I was drunk and trying to drive up
his leg and [ __ ] at some constant dealer
just unloading on the guy you know you
know we just it was a very unique
childhood that we had and I want people
to see how lucky we were in a way these
my daughter's never gonna have half the
fun that we had growing up I'm sure your
daughter's d me handle our about these
things or you know comes up you know I
don't bring it up what what stays in a
pack what's in the past stays in the
past I'll talk with you about this stuff
I get together like we were I was on a
PI the podcast I was on a zoom with
Higgins and wheeler and and Sharples the
other night and we wound up talking
about some of the swaggy stuff that we
did and it's just it's it's people who
weren't there don't truly appreciate it
thank you it had to be there is it was
so free we had so much freedom you know
to do what Oh almost whatever we wanted
and and thing was you know you went to
school you do you know you do what you
had to do you know we were in school did
my schoolwork I played sports I was an
athlete when I was on the field I was
there 100% and when you were out with
your friends you were there with them a
hundred percent hundred percent a
hundred percent everything you did you
did a hundred percent it was just it was
just it was a great time you know I
wrote the story out for them I'm doing
an audio book it's funny when I write
the stories out and then I read them and
I don't believe in myself I have to call
you or
BD or Luke's and just get confirmation
like I have to call a Devo sometimes my
case I have to call James and I really
got to get confirmation that this
happened you know because sometimes it
just feels like I was talking with you
mad about the Halloween party you went
over here and we dressed up like ghosts
I don't know what the [ __ ] we just know
we we you know everyone has yes no we're
not gonna mention it there was a reason
why we went because shadi a Chinese
nickname but I think if I remember but
yeah that was a crazy party up in up in
cameos attic yes garage and I think me
and Luke's had done some mescaline
that's what we called it in those days
yes the microdot mescaline and the clock
was moving fast but I was telling you
I'm I still know there was a hole the
middle of the ground with Atlanta to it
and your goal was to talk to somebody
and back them up so they could fall
through the hole you know you look at
that people fell through the hole
because they weren't paying attention
but then you had people like folk and
John Garrity and I think Kevin Valentine
they were diving down headfirst and he
go down they came up with his horns were
bent I just could not you know I still
be getting on a bus with you guys my job
was to torment the number-one bus driver
why I became a comedian on the number
Ward was like that's where I learned to
become a comedian because when you got
on the bus in the morning the bus came
in Jersey City and it was filled with
heroin addicts that would get methadone
I don't know how people don't remember
no I don't know I used to go I used to
be in the CIE work-study program so my
first classes at 7:30 so I would leave
[ __ ] 38th Street at 7:00 a.m. and
they would just open up that methadone
clinic so I would have to ride the bus
with a bunch of junkies Noddin and I
started waking it up my fart that was my
thing was just a fart at the bloaty Arum
and the junkies and thought oh my god
sophomore year we're coming back from
Bricktown after playing and the bus
broke down they had to send another bus
to get us we wind up playing the game
and they were coming back and it's super
late and we had Chili's on the bus with
us and everything like that and it's
it's cold out next thing you know people
are open windows thing gasping for air
it was you thank you just sit in the
back laughing like I eat everybody
else's stream and trying to get the
windows down all stuck that's what one
of the coaches said he's changing
flavors because I fought it what
happened was I was eating steak homes
and they got stuck in my system I had to
[ __ ] for like two weeks
what on that bus I didn't tell nobody
like I had this gastric problem and I do
a fart I still humble Laurie Rose there
was a name one of those rows of girls
Perrine after the second dose of farce
the cheerleader was crying and I'll
never forget laughing my ass so I wait
till this day people like who was
farting and they were they were blaming
but he's immediately
I blame somebody else Conti I believe
I'm blending
I blame something it's somebody else
let's beat them up you did you did I
think you blame them and you're laughing
I know it's you know
and people screaming over oh my god it
was it was classic [ __ ] Diaz Stephen
bill oh I love you I love you too
brother thank you for taking the time
man and uh if you want to check out you
have a Facebook page for the past
masters yeah out of the world touring
Zilla result
it's our websites TPM Rox calm and we're
also on Facebook just look for the past
masters all right brother
I love you thank you can doing this for
me my pleasure have a great week give
the girls a kiss you to do the same do
the same god and broke his leg
take care buddy he's evil so long guys
[Music]
the sound of it was the beginning was a
little [ __ ] up but you guys got the
hint how he grew up a little bit I mean
Steve wasn't a part of my criminal past
nothing like this we were just young
kids explore and like he said we went to
a bunch of concerts and his shed really
I mean like I had Dark Side of the Moon
but he introduced us to meet their
animals he introduced me to wish you
were here he introduced him and his
family introduced me there's so much
[ __ ] music
it was just pathetic I'm happy you got
to hear that Ted Nugent story when we
threw those chairs up in the end I
wasn't sitting with them I was sitting
on the side with this chick named Chris
Morgan was dear friend of mine and I
still remember throwing like three or
four chairs you know we got stories for
days and now I'm gonna keep bringing
them to you so funny he was saying that
things get bad he's thinking of Salma's
on the way he gonna say younger with
women like chubby women he goes nah guys
I go guys oh my god that's a brilliant
[ __ ] idea hey go to reddit.com they
got tons of people doing it go reddit
reddit calm ready any research meant
under with it like obviously women's
underwear it goes for a lot more because
the creepy guys like us buying it but I
saw people selling it for like
30:50 30 to 50 bucks a pair and Matei
some I'll take my [ __ ] little
uncircumcised dick I'll bang on to
jerk-offs I'll take the sperm more but
I'll rub it on the helmet to mix it up
with the pee it's like a sperm martini
don't think I'll show you my underwears
not me on these classic tighty whities
with a little skid mark just to take it
back I'll decorate it for you
I even fart man leave it it'll look like
a [ __ ] gotcha oh gosh I wore one of
those guns from the 14 shotguns no the
other ones the ones that spray like Oh
musket it looks like it's got shot with
a musket I'll show you more mm oh you
know me I got no [ __ ] shame yes I do
I can't summon not the way the man
that's torturing young smelling my dick
how would I sleep at night I'm a
Catholic you know I'm saying I can't put
up with that no I can't there's a lot of
[ __ ] I can't do guys but I just wouldn't
do I just can't do against Who I am and
who I belong you know it's like cameos
nice but I can't sell you a video me
yelling at you I want to make them video
me on that you trust me I'll yell at you
eventually if you liked oh they leave
with it [ __ ] that listen I hope you
enjoy these we're gonna do my friend
Dennis Colangelo on Wednesday next week
we're doing a two-parter with the man
who knows me better than anybody
this guy is my longest last thing he's
seen me at my worst and he's seen me at
my best I'm gonna give you a couple
weeks of these just to let you know what
the [ __ ] has happened so in the book the
audiobook gets released you guys are on
it you guys know that [ __ ] these are
bonafide and I want you to see what the
state of mind was the church would love
to introduce to you magic spoon let me
tell you something I'm happy magic spoon
sponsor sponsoring the show because
they're making they're making breakfast
fun again mmmm breakfast used to be
[ __ ] great you [ __ ] didn't even
pee you just ran downstairs to foster
your law and yeah like three different
select
is to pick from you know and you pour
them down and yeah yeah hating you talk
with your brother or your grandmother
what happened to those days we know what
happened they killed the serial would
surely you give a kid a bowl of cereal
you might as well get them give them a
head of mech they got no nutritional
value they got nothing that all changed
magic spoon magic spoon is making
breakfast feel like it's [ __ ] the
fourth of July say Christmas morning
they got flavor they got crunch of a
kids cereal but it's healthy for adults
you like Joey how can this be how zero
grams of sugar bean Delray's doing
backflips while we speak not only that
we got three net grams of carbs and each
serving and you get better anybody for
this one 12 grams of protein gluten free
and who needs surprise when you have all
that in the box nobody and it takes too
good to be true so whatever you're
craving they got all four flavors based
on all-time classics cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry plus a variety
pack that lets you try all flavors it's
like a walk down [ __ ] memory lane and
when you again that's all this is about
you're sick a [ __ ] oatmeal you buddy
know me like you were in prison for the
last six weeks and how many [ __ ] eggs
can you eat before you die right now
magic spoon gluten-free my favorite
flavor let me tell you something it's
the chocolate the cocoa and the birthday
cake when they said let me say how funny
was when they sent me to four boxes I
went on the website to see the flavors
just to investigate him and read up
everything and make sure there was no by
the way for you guys and I fell in love
with I was just wait to taste it and
that tremendous and for 11 grams of
[ __ ] protein I had a bowl just just
born it and then I checked it up against
another leading competitor on cereal my
daughter eats a cereal and I checked the
numbers on a Weight Watchers with what's
in [ __ ] cereal today you had a
blow-up this is the way to go if you're
in an adult this is the way to go if
you're on a diet this is the way to go
if you're diabetic this is the way if
you go
if you're gluten-free magic spoon so
right now go to magic spoon doc Tom's
last Church grab a variety pack and try
it be sure to press encode Church CH you
are CH and they're gonna throw in the
free shipping all right and magic spoon
is so confident their product its back
with 100% happiness guarantee
happy and peppy and bursting with life
banging and singing and dancing humbug
so if you don't like it for any reason
don't refund your Gita's no questions
asked
that's magic spoon dr. Tom's last Church
use promo code church for free shipping
I want to thank magic spoon but most
importantly I want to thank Stephen
Rebello
and I want to thank you guys for having
my back and for knowing that we're here
we're here I don't know how you're
feeling I know how you're making out
this week but for one hour I tried to
make you feel I [ __ ] him better right
and that's all that counts you know I
love you [ __ ] you know I got
your back my got the same [ __ ]
problems you got look at my hair I look
like Elvis gone wild I'm saying look at
my [ __ ] eyebrows I could [ __ ] bat
a [ __ ] eyebrow and get it off your
vain people were try and stay in enjoy
your families love your families look at
my hometown and lock Bergen number two
in the [ __ ] state of New Jersey and
and number three is Union City number
one is like what they got those [ __ ]
they're sitting Jews those bastards
no offense really you know I love you
but those bastard should be shot none
yeah
they don't [ __ ] dryclean their black
suit and then they don't take showers
it's like killing a skunk and taking a
skunk post-op off and putting it on top
of your a skunk to keep warm it's like
double trouble they're like double
skunks these [ __ ] icy Jews and I love
you no I want no harm and intended to
[ __ ] this to the Jews I love them but
we got to control the flow but most
importantly you got to keep on your game
and keep swinging dick in your mind let
me tell you something when this started
I was down you guys felt that my voice
listen to me now I don't give a [ __ ] I
got a plan I know exactly how I'm gonna
execute it and we got [ __ ] going
that's all that means whether you're
broke would ever get a plane going you
know what I don't know when this is
gonna end but when it does end you're
gonna be right there with your dick out
and somebody's gonna be down all fours
with that mouth open that's just the way
things work out sometimes I love your
[ __ ] I want to give a shout out
the magic spoon and I want to give out a
shout out to my bookie JG Ferguson [ __ ]
Saturday I'll see you guys Wednesday
morning tip top Magoo don't miss a beat
same bat-time same bat-channel
[Music]
take this [ __ ] mealy
[Music]